what's the deal with airplane peanuts
we've all heard of Comedians in Cars
Getting Coffee but what about Comedians
and elevators telling jokes long
elevator V last week I stumbled upon a
completely abandoned YouTube channel
that contained the treasures of a
thousand Kings video upon video of some
of the best New York comedians from
years ago telling jokes to strangers in
elevators hello welcome hi I had um sex
with my girlfriend recently and
afterwards she was like would you still
want to have sex with me I've gained 300
lb and I was like I don't know if it's
possible to have sex with a woman that
weighs 600
[Music]
lb pretty
good the coolest part about finding this
footage is that most of it's from well
over 6 years ago meaning the majority of
these Comics were not nearly as
established as they are
today hey guys how you doing Welcome to
the
elevator um big J erson not from these
parts but it seems like a great place uh
I'm Jewish but nobody can really tell
unless my pants are off cuz I have a
yamak on my [__] and two curly Hues next
to my balls I call it my
hdic
booya it's the only joke I ever wrote
down in my entire life all right thank
you guys so much been
amazing
hey how you doing how's it going how you
good good
a
uh an old man and an old lady are
getting ready for bed and the old woman
jumps out of the bathroom naked with a
cape on and yells out super [__] the
old man looks up and says I'll have this
soup it's long elevator ride that's one
joke hey hey gentlemen welcome to my gay
elevator uh you know I like the Jews
Jews are fun cuz uh it's the only
religion you can use as an adjective and
be like oh yeah Jeff's got curly hair
very neurotic kind of jewy you can't do
that with any other religion I can't be
like oh yeah Bob he won his wife Drive
kind of
Buzzy all right take your pants
off thank
you
kobby ra
all
[Music]
nobody's nobody's afraid of AIDS anymore
it's crazy it's insane I wanted to know
why I read an article the other day on
Facebook and it said you can live till
70 years old with AIDS if I had AIDS
right now it wouldn't even be in the top
10 things killing me I would go to the
doctor and he'd say the good news is you
have AIDS the bad news is your
cholesterol is high the AIDS might help
with that we don't
know I call my dad I'm like it's just
stage and he's like thank God you're
finally taking care of
yourself
so do you guys have
AIDS I always like to check I should
have checked before I did the joke but
people with AIDS like that
joke
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey
[Music]
AIDS
I only take ecstasy when I go see my
family cuz it makes me love them the
last time I did it I ended up
motorboating my Aunt
Sheila I put my face in her tin
went
crazy I'd blow you if I thought we'd
both enjoy it oh my God I got to go I
used to be good at that cuz I like I got
to get in my studio see y
later
Kanye I sent to my girlfriend and how
about a good night F she shook my hand
said good night
[Music]
fu remember to tip your white
Jes two gay guys are at the house one
guys goes I'm bored the guy let's play
hide and seek I'll hide and if you find
me I'll blow you the other guy goes what
if I can't find you he goes I'll be
behind the
couch back in the new people in the
crowd guys welcome to Comedy on elevator
I'm your host H fley good to see you
thanks for coming good looking couple is
this your sister I like where this is
going what part of West Virginia are you
guys from just roughly about huh see how
things go if she's not good enough for
anybody else's family if she's not good
enough for yours I see how this works
out it's very nice miss you married does
he know you're here with him that's what
we want to know does he know that it's
going on in the elevator here and guys
that's our time thank you so much take
care of all
right
how you doing girls hey I was wondering
them I mean like I haven't done this
since high school you know so um you
mind if I titty [__] you
guys I'm just say you know it's innocent
enough you know we don't have to kiss
it's like handshake really is yeah it's
not you know all you got to do is just
hold them together I'll do the
rest work if you can get I bring my own
towel
hey what up hey welcome to the [__]
elevator we test your [__] all right
yeah all right here's a joke I'm going
to tell you a joke right this is one of
my favorite Street jokes of all time
okay it's a little long so just uh you
know bear with me three guys die go to
heaven right there's not enough room
Peter's like look he's at the Pearly
Gates I don't have enough room I'll I'll
hear your stories one by one whoever
died the most violent death I'll allow
you into heaven everybody's like all
right fine so they go in they go Peter's
office first guy comes in he goes all
right what happened to you he goes okay
check it out I worked hard all day I
come home to the apartment I come in
this romantic music playing this
candle's lit I know she's banging
somebody okay so I check the the shower
she's in there but she's alone okay I
check the kitchen I check the cabinets I
check out of the bed I can't find them
there's no all of a sudden I look there
he is hanging off the balcony I go out
and I stop punching his hands he won't
fall I start kicking his hands he still
won't fall I get a hammer I smack his
hand falls off down to the bushes I look
he's still alive I go get the fridge I
throw it off the balcony onto him he's
dead I'm so distraught from this I take
a shotgun I blow my brain St Peter's
like wow that's a that's a bad one all
right let me hear the next guy so the
next guy comes in he's like what
happened to you he goes all right check
it out I'm on my exercise bike in my
apartment the curtain gets caught in my
wheel I go flying off my balcony I grab
the guy's balcony beneath me this
lunatic comes out starts punching my
hands kicking my hands then he gets a
hammer smashes my hands until I fall
then end of the bushes I think I'm dead
I'm not I'm alive I look up this [__]
throws a fridge on me kills me I'm dead
that's pretty bad he goes let me hear
the last guy last guy comes in he goes
what happened to you he goes all right
I'm naked in the
fridge did you get it the guy she was
[__] was in the in the fridge
you
God all right I got to go get the [__]
out of my all right wait a minute
whoever's going to blow me please
[Music]
stay for the team
buddy two guys are at the Ferrari
dealership and they're standing next to
a brand new Ferrari the salesman comes
out and he says gentlemen are you
thinking about buying a Ferrari and the
guy says no we're buying a Ferrari sorry
we're thinking about
[__] thank you good
[Music]
night there's dozens more of these gems
on the laugh it up comedy club YouTube
channel if you want to check them out
although they haven't posted in 4 years
so you will eventually run out of
content but if you want multiple new
videos every single week about all your
favorite comedians just subscribe to
joke World thanks for watching
joke
world that's it J
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out